whether you're a fan of Piper and her
underground underwear ring or you just
love Alex because she's basically Jon
Snow if he was into drug smuggling and
fierce eyebrows you'll be glad to know
that orange is the new black is coming
back soon but we warned there be
spoilers ahead I'm Lucy and this is your
jailhouse rock gamespot news update
Netflix has released some new stills
from the upcoming fourth season of
orange is the new black by the looks of
it things are going to get pretty
intense one image showcases a gagged
Piper Chapman with tears in her eyes
with her hand extended and on the brink
of receiving some kind of prison Justice
season very ended by showcasing
construction teams adding bunk beds to
accommodate more prisoners one of the
new inmates is Judy King who's played by
Blair Brown who's based on former TV
cooking personality Martha Stewart she
can be seen in these new images while
another sad still in the gallery shows
Laverne Cox his character who was put
into security housing unit during season
three orange is the new black season 4
premieres on jun 17 three further
seasons are also on the way bringing the
hit Netflix show up to seven total
creator Jenji Kohan will remain on board
for the further three seasons are you
excited for the new season of orange is
the new black which of the inmates are
you hoping will die horribly let me know
in the comments or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot com